José Legault Véronique prince allait
Caston gay bonsoir
je vous montre un tableau ou deux puis
on va parler de ces plaintes reçues par
le fils de la langue française du fils
québécois de la langue française qui
explose regardez des chiffres d'abord
des voilées ce midi par TVA qui ont été
ensuite envoyé à tous les médias
regarder 2018 il y avait 2807
684 2022 2023 c'est quand même trois
fois plus ou presque
housse ou d'où proviennent ces plaintes
quel commerce sont visés c'est beaucoup
les chaînes Tim Hortons et le champion
mec dans l'ordre 70 et A&W donc chaîne
de restauration rapide
65 en a d'autres là évidemment on n'a
pas tout mis dans quelle région vous
serez pas étonné c'est à Montréal le
gros des plaintes
61%, monter régie 11% Laval donc
Rive-Sud de Rive-Nord capitaine
nationale plus 5 ou taway 4
Laurentides de 3 alors ça vous donne une
idée le portrait José explosion des
plaintes les gens sont plus conscients
ou les ou ça se détériore ou les deux à
la fois
évidemment dans le domaine des
impressions
l'impression c'est que c'est
probablement une combinaison des deux
et d'après ce qu'on peut en comprendre
où ce qu'on peut en tout cas ils mettent
comme hypothèse
ce serait surtout j'imagine des plaintes
Venas de personnes peut-être dans la
quarantaine cinquantaine soixantaine qui
sont un peu plus conscientisés c'est pas
pour blâmer les plus jeunes on sait que
les plus jeunes sont moins conscientisés
en général sur cette question là donc
j'entendais le ministre Jean-François
Robert je veux dire que c'est grâce à
l'arrivée de la CAQ en 2018 là
l'atmosphère le nationalisme etc
tout à fait j'aimerais savoir tes
preuves de ça là mais j'ai plus
l'impression que c'est une combinaison
des recul du français qui s'accentue
dans la grande région de Montréal et en
même temps il y a peut-être une partie
de la population qui en est plus
consciente et qui et qui et qui sont en
plein
concrètement mais il faudra avoir des
données un petit peu plus un peu mieux
un petit peu plus ventilique ça tout à
fait je vais vous faire entendre tout à
l'heure le ministre mes premiers tours
de table Véronique presse premier
constat quand vous voyez ça là
effectivement José l'a dit la taxe
attribue le mérite mais moi je vais lui
donner en partie le mérite tout comme je
vais le donner aux autres partis
politiques pour ceux que je dis que je
lui donne en partie c'est que je pense
que toutes les formations ont contribué
à conscientiser parce qu'à partir du
moment où vous avez un parti politique
qui dit c'est moi qui a le meilleur plan
français puis je vais mettre en place
des mesures mais là il y a un autre
partie qui va dire mais non c'est nous
les meilleures défenseurs du français on
a encore un meilleur plan plus il y a
une surenchère qui s'est créée dans les
dernières années nous surenchères
politiques puis je crois que ça
contribué à une conscientisation
collective parce qu'il y avait un
consensus politique qui a fait en sorte
que ça s'y retrouver ce débat là dans
l'espace public parce que si les élus
n'avaient pas participé à ce débat là
puis c'était pas un peu entre déchirer
entre eux à savoir qui est le meilleur
pour faire survivre la langue française
mais peut-être que ça aurait pas eu
autant d'écho dans les salons déjà Alec
oui
je fais entendre le ministre après José
enfants
96 depuis la réforme de la Charte de la
langue française
ce que j'osais dit est également vrai ça
veut dire qu'on en a davantage parlé il
y a des gens donc qui sont plus
sensibles à ça et l'autre phénomène qui
s'est passé depuis 5 ans depuis 5 ans
c'est la pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui
c'est largement accentué
particulièrement pour des des emplois
qui sont à bosse à l'air comme la
restauration comme chez McDo comme
j'étais Morton comme je suis W on est
dans une situation où les commerçants
pour rester ouvert en bronze à peu près
n'importe qui parce qu'il manque de
monde et ici parle pas français on va
faire de notre mieux dites bonjour puis
est-ce que vous pouvez on est dans cette
situation là ça n'excuse pas tout je
pense que des bannières qui devraient
faire davantage d'efforts dans leur
recrutement mais ça peut certainement
expliquer une dégradation dans certains
secteurs notamment l'île de Montréal où
on en a des étudiants étrangers des
travailleurs étrangers qui sont
peut-être capables de donner combler des
postes que plus personne n'est
préoccuper et il parle pas toujours très
bien français ce qui a peut-être suscité
des plaintes et qui a donc avec la
confidence conscientisation ambiante
fait exploser le nombre de places pour
avoir une conjoncture du débat politique
de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre de la
difficulté à recruter probablement tous
ensemble depuis cinq ans on va écouter
le ministre on revient
je me réjouis moi devant les Québécois
ne pas se laisser être servi dans une
autre langue que le français de voir que
les Québécois portent plein il faut
qu'on fasse ça il faut qu'on demande à
être servi en français l'objectif c'est
pas donné des amants l'objectif c'est de
franciser nos milieux de travail
l'affichage et le service des gens
Joseph vous alliez dire
non je disais c'est sûr que il y a en
effet une conscientisation sur sur le
plan politique c'est pour ça que je
tenais pas tout le mérite à la carte
parce que comme le dit Véronique c'est
le propre de plusieurs partis politiques
même Justin Trudeau reconnaît le fils de
Pierre Trudeau reconnaît que le français
recule au Québec alors c'est quand même
une avancée considérable sur sur le plan
des de cette de cette prise de
conscience là
étant dit peut-être que c'est mon âge
avancé qui parle mais il y a deux
manières de voir ça on peut toujours se
réjouir comme le ministre le fait puis
dire ah bon d'accord il y a des gens qui
se plaignent plus d'accord mais en même
temps moi ça me ramène en arrière aussi
et ça rappelle que normalement c'est pas
aux citoyen à faire ça si les citoyens
sont dans une situation où ils doivent
se plaindre de l'absence de français
dans la langue d'accueil dans la langue
de commerce et dans la langue
d'affichage là on parle de ces de ces
lorsqu'on regarde les différents types
de plaintes c'est quand quelque part les
gouvernements n'ont pas fait leur
travail non plus que la Ville de
Montréal n'a pas fait son travail et ça
ça fait 25 ans je l'ai je lui répétais
souvent mais il y a eu une inaction leur
profonde que durée depuis le dernier
référendum sur le front linguistique et
ça ça a été le propre autant du Parti
québécois que
libéral la cacophonie dans la bonne
direction avec la loi 96 mais écoutez là
ça sera très difficilement le 25 ans de
l'inaction donc moi pour moi c'est de
placer les citoyens en situation de
celui dans monter on appelait ça la
guérilla linguistique
moi je trouve ça je trouve ça un peu
malaisant mais c'est aussi un aveu de de
du résultat de cette action là José
vient d'en parler à Ottawa hier c'était
l'adoption de la loi de la nouvelle Loi
sur les langues officielles qui
reconnaît il y a un changement de
philosophie
qui reconnaît que le français davantage
menacé que l'anglais au Canada un seul à
votre compte Alex et Anthony député ici
dans l'ouest de Montréal que l'on voit
les trois tous les autres partis il faut
le souligner quand même ont appuyé cette
loi là qui
adopte les des mesures de la loi 101 au
Québec qui d'ailleurs le ministre
québécois c'était réjoui à l'époque de
son entente avec le fédéral alors on
s'en va où avec ça à la question
en fait au gouvernement du Québec on est
plutôt content les fédérations
acadiennes franco-montarienne sont très
heureux aussi de cette avancée-là ça
faisait quand même très longtemps qu'il
y avait cette loi avait pas été
dépoussiérée il y a maintenant une
reconnaissance asymétrique que le
français est également à protéger au
Québec et donc pas seulement donc à
l'extérieur du Québec donc beaucoup de
bonnes choses Anthony et a eu la
permission de son parti pour voter
contre parce qu'il y a et ça le demeure
réelle une grogne dans la communauté
anglophone montréalaise par rapport à ce
débat là surtout qui viennent la loi 96
et qu'on fait référence à la loi 96 donc
à la Charte canadienne à la Charte
québécoise la langue française dans un
dans une loi fédérale ça ça passe moins
bien surtout qu'on utilise la clause
dérogatoire la Constitution pour être
capable de la faire passer donc il est
un peu l'espèce de porte drapeau chez
les libéraux de ceux qui disent bah
écoutez on vous a pas oublié on est
conscient à la communauté anglophone que
vous êtes pas heureux vous n'êtes pas
content mais en ayant un seul député qui
va de ce côté là qui n'est pas membre du
cabinet qui est pas je vous conseille
des ministres dans tout le Parlement
au début un certain moment on se
demandait si elle n'avait pas être même
plus 7 8 députés libéraux qui est
insatisfait qui voulait modifier la loi
Marc Garnaud souvenez-vous était de
ceux-là là on a finalement une seule
personne qui s'y oppose c'est pas majeur
mais c'est ça témoigne d'une sorte de
certaines inconfort dans la communauté
Montréal par rapport à ce débat là puis
on va le on voit entre guillemets
l'accepter là on va dire du côté des
libéraux Véronique rapidement là-dessus
et José
oui en fait du côté Québec ça apporte de
l'eau moulin pour le plan d'action qui
va être déposé dans peut-être un mois ou
deux maximum un plan d'action justement
où on voit se servir tu as comme une
espèce de Crescendo là où on dit ben
voyez toutes les mesures qui ont été
mises en place mais là on va y aller on
va ajouter une autre couche puis on va
mettre d'autres mesures en place c'est
sûr que ces 13 il le voit comme une
bataille qu'ils ont remporté du côté de
Québec oui parce qu'on est en attente
Véronique Fabienne le mentionné on est
temps d'attendre de ce que je vais
reprendre l'expression de madame Marois
d'un bouquet de mesure à Québec un plan
d'action et
c'est pas nécessairement un projet de
loi mais ça peut quand même être sous
forme de mobilisation ou promotion de la
langue
oui mais sur le
vampire de la Loi sur les langues
officielles faudrait pas oublier Mélanie
jolie parce que c'était elle vraiment
comme ministre qui a toute initié cette
révision évidemment avec la pluie de son
premier ministre Justin Trudeau comme
comme on disait tout à l'heure qui a
reconnu cet asymétrie là entre les deux
langues officielles donc c'est pour rien
et donc ça participe de tout de tout ce
mouvement là maintenant concrètement sur
le terrain au Québec pour les
communautés franco-québecoises ben il va
s'agir de voir si la marchandise va être
livrée va être opérationnalisée dans les
communautés elles-mêmes très bien je
recevais Manon Macé on va parler dans
une seconde mais je vous refais
entendre un extrait du discours de
monsieur Legault dimanche où il ne
parlait plus vous avez un texte José
là-dessus ce matin il ne parlait plus de
QS mais bien de du Parti québécois comme
étant il le définissait comme étant son
principal adversaire maintenant on
écoute donc monsieur Legault et Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon en réaction puis
on revient
problème avec le PQ c'est qui mise tout
sur le grand soir de la souveraineté des
pékistes nous disent
faut protéger la laïcité il faut
protéger la langue on est là-dessus
d'accord mais faut agir puis pour agir
maintenant il faut être au gouvernement
puis pour être au gouvernement faut
rassembler à ses mondes à cette
nationalistes et c'est ça la CAQ le plus
grand rassemblement de nationalistes au
Québec
on constate qu'il visait spécifiquement
le Parti québécois il a raison de le
faire là c'est bel et bien son principal
adversaire et c'est François Legault
nous attaque de cette manière c'est pour
détourner l'attention d'un gouvernement
qui de plus en plus perd la confiance de
la population parce qu'il a dit des
choses elle s'est engagée cette
formation politique de la claque à faire
des choses pour ensuite faire exactement
l'inverse
je vous rappelle dernier élément pour
ajouter à la discussion sondage Léger du
2 mai qui avait monté qui avait montré
un recul de la carte le premier et une
poussée du Parti québécois ça c'est pour
tout le Québec mais regardez dans la
région de Québec troisième lien bien sûr
déception parce que quoi qui engrange le
vote de mécontents enfin le déplacement
de mes contentement et les autres partis
c'est ça bouge pas là ça bouge pas même
Québec solidaire et c'est voilà libéraux
sont à 6 dans la région de Québec donc
José vous avez écrit là-dessus ce matin
on le sent en fait monsieur Legault lit
les sondages comme les autres le voit
bien que le parti qui monte c'est le PQ
oui oui et c'est un autre jeu qu'avec
solidaire parce que monsieur Legault on
se souviendra vers l'élection j'utilise
le mot Coralie avec couronné Gabriel à
12 mois comme étant son adversaire
principal évidemment c'était c'est
un cadeau pour Québec solidaire ça lui a
pas servi à grand-chose évidemment mais
bon ça c'est une autre histoire là c'est
vraiment le Parti québécois et comme
monsieur Legault et lui-même un ex-minis
particulier
on s'en souviendra bon il a changé son
point de vue il a créé la calque
justement pour s'éloigner de ça partie
nationaliste mais non souverainiste mais
là que ce soit son ancien son ancien
sérail qui viennent un petit peu le
hanter ben ça lui demande quand même une
certaine habilité moi je l'ai trouvé
habile dimanche il n'a pas diabolisé la
partie québécois il vient de là il
pourrait pas le faire il n'a pas dit que
son option était dangereuse comme les
libéraux l'ont répété pendant des
décennies il a dit non non écoutez nous
on est nationaliste nous on est au
pouvoir nous on peut agir et depuis ce
temps-là ben pas saint-pierre-flammon
donc quand même je pense va profiter ou
lui aussi de ce côté là justement
d'avoir été
béni adversaire principal du Premier
ministre quand même qui est très très
populaire et on a vu aussi que depuis ce
temps-là le Parti québécois publié une
longue liste est-ce que le PQ avait fait
lorsqu'il était des fois qu'il a été au
pouvoir malgré qu'il y avait son option
souverainiste il y a fait beaucoup
beaucoup de choses dont la loi 101
donc c'est ça va être intéressant de
voir comment
cette nouvelle ce nouveau duo là va
c'est un peu c'est comme si Monsieur le
goût avait fait du judo finalement avec
la remontée du PQ dans les sondages et
qu'il avait fait quand même de manière
assez courtoise on sait pas si ça va
durer ça va rester courtois
comme il vient de là effectivement il
peut pas diaboliser comme dit José mais
lui il plaide le pragmatisme
pour l'instant on est essentiellement
dans la rhétorique parce que
concrètement le mouvement dans les
interventions de vote qu'on a vu dans
sondage Léger il est uniquement dû à la
région de Québec en raison du troisième
lien qui est un endroit assez aride
depuis longtemps pour le Parti québécois
je suis pas certain qu'on soit capable
de faire beaucoup de gains des élections
avaient lieu demain matin et le PQ ne
bouge pas ailleurs au Québec ça bouge
pas dans le 4 5 0 au nord de Montréal ça
bouge pas à monter Régis ça bouge pas en
esprit il se passe rien au Saguenay et
donc ce qu'on voit comme mouvement
actuellement c'est essentiellement la
région de Québec qui est le château fort
de la CAQ peut-être que ça va se
confirmer de sondage en sondage
peut-être que dans trois ans le Parti
québécois va être le parti dominant dans
la région de Québec si la CAC avait je
pense que la carte devrait s'inquiéter
si ça si ça se déplacement là fait huile
et que ça commence à réfléchir chez les
électeurs nationalistes du 4-5-0 du
Saguenay ou là on a des bases
historiques très fortes au PQ oui il y a
beaucoup de circonscriptions en jeu
d'élection en élection donc là peut-être
à cette garder le couvercle sur la
marmite parce que d'un point de vue
stratégique il y a pas beaucoup de
dangers nulle part sauf la raison de
Québec comme je le dis c'est difficile
historiquement pour le PQ mais si on
devait commencer à avoir un narratif le
PQ revient à la vie qui pourrait être à
force d'opposition principale à la CAQ
et que là dans d'autres régions ça bouge
là il y aurait danger donc je pense une
frappe préventive de François Legault
qui commence à tester un peu ses lignes
c'est intéressant c'est une frappe
préventive comme vous dites mais en
faisant cette frappe préventive il aide
pas ses pieds à Plamondon Véronique
comme étant crédible et présent et
vivant et bien vivant il lui fait une
fleur perceptable était content lundi le
devenir parler devenir vous voir
Véronique
lui
vécu en fait la CAQ
le voit dans son rétroviseur il est
encore loin mais il le voit quand même
puis moi la façon que je m'amuse un
petit peu ça c'est comme la marmotte qui
vient creuser si on trouve sur son
terrain sur ton terrain plus tu dis tant
qu'elle vient manger juste quelques
carottes dans le potager c'est correct
on peut cohabiter mais évidemment
prendre des mesures alors le j'entends
déjà des gens dire mais sinon bien
simpliste comme métaphore mais la
politique c'est tellement simple parfois
les gens qui votent pour la CAQ ce sont
beaucoup des anciens pékistes des
anciens libéraux vous regardez le Parti
libéral il se cherche il y a pas de chef
vous regardez le Parti québécois il a un
jeune chef charismatique qui se dit moi
je vais essayer de faire de la politique
autrement je vais pas être partisan puis
qui s'assume aussi qui dit ben nous on
va en parler de la souveraineté alors la
carte elle est confortable quand c'est
Québec solidaire sont principales
adversaire confortable parce que c'est
pas du tout le même électoral les gens
qui votent pour cuisiner pour la CAQ et
vice versa mais à partir du moment
c'est ça et puis à partir du moment où
les gens se disent ouais c'est peut-être
mon deuxième choix finalement le PQ ben
là le vase communicant il est évident et
c'est sûr que la carte doit surveiller
l'analogie de la marmotte elle est elle
est non seulement bonne mais elle est
précise que tu fais parce que la CAQ et
le PQ la bourre le même jardin alors
c'est le même électorat ce sont des
vases communicants la cacolat siphonné
l'électrotique
aussi une partie de l'électorat
libérationnels
donc c'est c'est vraiment ça et oui elle
est corraison dans la région de Québec
c'est peut-être temporaire mais ce qui
dérange à la CAQ c'est que le PQ c'est
ici depuis l'élection en deuxième
position chez les francophones qui ce
qui menacent pas la base de la cape pour
le moment mais c'est quand même un
phénomène politique intéressant que le
PQ est réussi à SEIC au deuxième
masser que je recevais sur ce plateau
qui ne sera plus confortable on se
connaît je cherche
le petit message antique monsieur
Legault qui dit bon ben dans le dans les
circonstances je vous salue j'adorais
dit-il débattre avec Manon durant les
années parce qu'on se souvient que Manon
ma sœur fait un débat des chefs
c'était elle qui était la chef
parlementaire donc qui était au débat
des chefs à l'époque donc ils ont ils
ont eu à exprimer ensemble
qui va s'occuper de sa circonscription
elle ne dit pas ça va être se
représenter ou pas mais c'est sa
décision on verra mais donc elle sera
beaucoup moins présente comment vous
avez vu ça
je pense que c'est une bonne décision
je pense qu'elle a donné ce qu'elle
avait à donner on la sentait un petit
peu moins
engagé motivé dans les derniers mois
c'est correct après tout ce qu'elle a
fait elle a l'impression que c'est
peut-être que quelqu'un d'autre pourrait
mieux faire le travail qu'elle puis elle
me quitte donc au bon moment je pense il
y a toute une réflexion à Québec
solidaire actuellement sur comment on
fait pour séduire les régions quelle
position devrait prendre donc on a une
préparation à faire avant les prochaines
élections et d'avoir un nouveau visage
comme cours porte-parole je pense que
c'est le bon moment je sais que
plusieurs noms qui circulent
probablement que vos bagazal serait
excellente mais je pense que pour
l'avenir de Québec solidaire on devrait
se pencher sur une candidature féminine
de l'extérieur de Montréal un moment
donné c'est bien de dire on veut séduire
les régions on veut sortir de Montréal
mais faudra le prouver concrètement puis
avoir une courte parole que ce soit
Christine l'abri à Sherbrooke que ce
soit Émilie Lessard terrier de rando ou
quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas obligé
d'être une élu ou une ancienne élue à
Québec solidaire mais quelqu'un qui
donne qui donne un
très rapidement avant même qu'il soit
élu mais oui mais je dis sortir de
Montréal l'idée de sortir la changer la
recette aussi parce qu'on sait que un
petit ralentissement peut-être
José là-dessus
ben moi je trouve ça extraordinaire
qu'aujourd'hui bon Manon martiniquait
pas son côté là mais quitte son rôle de
cours comme cours porte-parole et c'est
l'unanimité tout le monde salut
l'importance de Manon masser son rôle
politique très important son humanisme
sa capacité de défendre les gens qui
sont des sans voix qui sont souvent
ignorées par les décideurs politiques et
cette femme qui a assumé aussi que elle
est qui elle est elle est ce qu'elle est
l'apparence qu'elle a elle est une belle
femme elle est naturelle elle est je
pense que c'est une avancée considérable
pour les femmes et heureusement pour les
électeurs de son côté elle ne s'en va
pas mais je pense quand même que pour
Québec solidaire de la perdre comme Cope
porte-parole je pense que ça va quand
même faire un peu mal quelques secondes
Véronique mais moi je pense que les
autres partis politiques se disaient
bonne affaire pour nous ça parce que
Manon Massé aller chercher une frange
d'électorat différente puis à la portée
un ton différent puis elle avait un
respect qui était assez unanime merci
beaucoup José Véronique Alec à très
bientôt bonne soirée au revoir bonne
soirée au revoir